hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an intriguing and mind-blowing science
fiction movie from black mirror seasons
5 called striking vipers
black mirror is an anthology series
meaning that you do not need to watch
the previous episode to understand this
movie
the movie begins with danny parker and
his girlfriend theo who go to a
nightclub and both of them pretend to be
strangers but not for a long time
because carl suddenly shows up and
introduces his new girlfriend daisy to
them
turns out that roleplay act turns theo
on thus the couple decide to go home and
have fun
danny awakens in the middle of the night
finding carl who has been waiting for
him while playing a console game
he then joins carl playing the action
game called striking vipers
they play till morning and it is
revealed that carl always picks a young
woman character named roxette while
danny keeps choosing lance however they
are too loud and it wakes theo up who is
very upset with the boys 11 years later
danny who has now become a grown-up man
conducts a barbecue party at his house
to celebrate his birthday
surprisingly he is also married to theo
with whom he has a three-year-old child
named tyler
after losing contact with danny for a
long time carl shows up at danny's house
and theo warmly welcomes him
he tells theo that he broke up with
daisy
he subsequently comes in and gives his
best friend a birthday present
danny opens the gift and turns out it is
the latest series of striking vipers
game striking viper's ex along with the
virtual reality device
shortly after they have a beer together
and carl reveals his new girlfriend
mariella to danny and theo
while washing all the dishes theo
appears and suggests his husband to hang
out more with his friends because he has
been spending all his time on work and
ignores his social life
she also wants to invite carl to their
family dinner the following day which
danny reluctantly agrees to
on the other hand carl is living a more
youthful lifestyle without having to
think about family and other stressful
stuff
just after his wife goes to sleep danny
plays tetris while he suddenly gets an
invitation from carl to play striking
viper's ex
he puts the game chip into the
controller and sticks the vr device to
his head
as expected carl still picks roxat as
his main character while danny plays as
lance as the game commences they fall
back motionless on their couches
danny is shocked when he finds out that
he is in the game and is able to control
the character without using the
controller before they begin to fight
carl warns his best friend that the game
emulates physical sensation the fight
ensues and it seems like danny is no
match to carl as his avatar roxette
manages to beat his character down
easily
carl eventually wins the first round and
dany feels real pain as his character is
hurt fortunately the injuries
immediately disappear at the end of the
round
during their battle in the second round
carl kisses danny using his avatar but
danny immediately pulls away and quits
the game
danny who is still shocked with what has
just happened goes to bed and sleep
the next day while his wife is away
danny puts tyler to bed and then
immediately plays striking viper's axe
with carl again
they choose the same characters as usual
and this time dany has gotten accustomed
to his new body of lance
instead of fighting they kiss each other
through their avatars
a few moments later danny is forced to
exit the game after his son distracts
him by kicking him
still that evening theo returns home and
attempts to tease his husband who shows
no interest towards her
since then danny and carl regularly meet
up and make love virtually in the game
they both enjoy the feeling as the game
emulates physical sensation
meanwhile theo notices a change in her
relationship with danny as he keeps
rejecting her request to have sexual
intercourse
at some point danny through his avatar
asks carl about the feeling of being in
a woman's body he replies that it's
satisfying and they both begin to kiss
again
to make things worse danny even forgets
his wedding anniversary with theo which
upsets her
he informs carl that he can't play
tonight as he plans to have a romantic
dinner with his wife in the restaurant
theo brings up the topic about them not
having intercourse for a while despite
their plan to have a baby
danny makes it clear that nothing is
going on and it's just him who is tired
lately that night danny locks the game
in the vr device in a cabinet he even
ignores carl's messages until he calls
him to clarify everything telling him
that he cannot do the forbidden
relationship anymore
this shattered carl's heart but he
couldn't do anything
seven months later theo is finally
pregnant and she secretly invites carl
to come to celebrate dany's birthday
long story short carl arrives and they
have dinner together when theo leaves
the room carl admits that he has tried
to replace him with the ai and other
players in the game but he states that
the sensation is incomparable when he
did it with danny he once even tried it
with a polar bear but he just couldn't
get danny out of his mind
unfortunately danny refuses to play the
game and the dinner continues
during the night danny can't sleep and
changes his mind
he plays the game and the pair are
having fun again
at some point carl tells danny that he
loves him
danny is furious because he is unsure of
his feelings thus he asks carl to meet
up in real life
they arrive at a parking lot and they
kiss in their real bodies to see if
there's any connection between them
both of them admit they feel nothing
during the kiss but carl still insists
that it's a different feeling if they do
it in the game
they fight because danny refuses to do
it again until the police come and
arrest them sometimes later theo comes
to the police station to release his
husband on their way back home theo asks
danny what's happening between him and
his best friend but he doesn't say a
single word
at the end of the movie it's dany's
birthday again but something weird
happens as theo allows his husband to
have a virtual relationship in the game
with carl while she can go out to a bar
without her wedding ring and meet up
with a stranger at the exchange
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching